11 руки в промиваємо до 144 ви міг
євросоюзу шлях України до безвізового
режиму був довгим і тернистим терені
формально до і ви до нас осьовим про ви ж
за право ж не обсяг це особистий паспорт
доу хвала не антикорупційних законів
граматики та активісти нарікаю українською
влада добру роботу створених після
євромайдану антикорупційних органів
the sabbath у та електронне
декларування
зводу чин вони адже у сиду seo вона не
решти трьох років у серці за 1 пара
творилися вона бутафорію там ще ми
боремося за інституті you якуна магазину
відпрацює вибитий вати
набір мусе закон за законом дарства його
по траху намокають і розстебнутий наш
матки
якщо у супроводі без візу ситуація в
україні може [ __ ] shit is a працювати і
активісти ж без віз і з успішно
ти з на українську владу для
прошивання реформ у витрачання брюсселем
цілий інструмент
може розв'язати руки нинішньої
політичній еліті України століття правда
поверну-то сюди звучного їй доніс прав
але тут його рота ніби обоє рожна я
буду тут не води під ребра лизати інший
моніторних ситуації в Україні і від я все
буду
величин ще й перший вид назад
класна на щит може стати причиною
запуску тіло механізми продуктами так
що план троль будди
гілок і всі українські влади араб там
спади на думку заробіток рок тому через
панікери форма у сфері протезе та
корупції безвізовий режим може прозу
планети в team vs пари каноні ще дати
його знайдіть у брюсселі вірити можна і
весь вид брата без віз
та й кого україною йшла устілки років ще
ближче і ви інструмент позов на українську
владу лише сама з косово невис